bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france dans ce contexte dramatique
qu'est ce que vous attendez de la coop
mai ce qu'on attend de la coop 26
érodera pu me rattraper le retard qui a
été qui a été pris depuis tant d'années
en fait parce que là les plus question
de mesurettes et les questions de
grandes mesures et surtout d'actions
quand emmanuel macron parle d'ambition
de transparence mais on attend de ça de
lui depuis le début c'est même vraiment
il fait preuve de ces du toupet du
mépris de dire ça je veux dire le retard
c'est lui qu'il a pris il a été un très
très mauvais élèves la france a été très
mauvaise élève depuis les accords de
paris on donne 15 on avait les accords
de paris avait pour vocation de prendre
des mesures pour respecter les 1,5
degrés d'augmentation du climat d'ici la
fin du siècle et au final le rapport du
giec de 2021 annonce que c'est un deuil
au 5° vont être atteint dès 2030 donc on
voit que le retard et pris le problème
c'est qu'on est dans une dans une chute
dans une dune plus ça va plus ça
s'empire si vous voulez c'est une courbe
exponentielle
donc si on n'agit pas maintenant tout de
suite c'est trop tard et d'ailleurs le
gicl a dit on a atteint un point de non
retour donc ce qu'on attend nous en tout
cas à la rave cd très grande mesure
surtout des actions concrètes tout de
suite et pourtant la france apparaisse
sur la scène internationale comme un
acteur majeur en matière de la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique ce
que vous dites c'est qu'il ya finalement
un décalage entre les propos tenus par
emmanuel macron dans ce genre de
conférence c'est ça mon politique en
matière d'écologie
il ya un décalage mais total depuis le
début et tout le monde le dit malgré le
fait qu'en 2018 il a été sacré champion
de la terre parce que c'est quand même
hallucinant je viens il ya une double
condamnation vis-à-vis de l'état
français par le conseil d'administration
le conseil d'état le tribunal
d'administration pardon par rapport à
ces non respect d'engagements son
inaction climatique là le budget qu'il a
une manuelle macro entre les mains ils
utilisent pour ouvrir des centrales
nucléaires alors certes il joue sur le
fait que au niveau co2 il n'y a pas
d'émission de gaz à effet de serre avec
les centrales mais je viens l'écologie
ça se finit pas seulement réchauffement
climatique c'est un ensemble il parle
lui-même de biodiversité mais il faut
tout prendre en compte dans cette
situation est d'ailleurs pas qu'on parle
de biodiversité des océans mais il fait
tout l'inversé ils dénoncent les pays
qui cite des traités commerciaux
climaticides mais c'est incroyable de
dire quelque chose pareille c'est
lui-même qui cite ce genre de traiter
avec des gros industriels pollueurs il
ne taxe pas assez ses gros pollueurs
donc ses limites ça serait rigolo si ce
n'était pas un enjeu planétaire est
dramatique ça serait un sketch ne s'est
pas drôle du tout il parle d'ambition il
est clairement en ambition
présidentielle actuellement c'est de la
com alors on a l'impression d'entendre à
chaque conférence de ce type cette même
dramaturgique pour quel résultat au
final quand on voit le peu d'ambition en
tout cas le peu de clarté du g20 en
matière de lutte contre le réchauffement
alors qu'on le rappelle le g20
représente à lui seul 80% des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre
oui je pense que c'est un enjeu de
communication c'est pour dire qu'ils
font des choses c'est comme quand tu es
meilleur accroc a encadré la convention
citoyenne pro clima il avait promis
beaucoup de choses au final la plupart
des propositions ont été détricoté est
annulé
discrètement en de façon fourbe donc je
pense simplement que c'est c'est
vraiment un c'est de la com donc il ya
des sponsors en plus dans ce genre de
rassemblement qui sont ultra
pollueurs lancer des grosses grosses
industries donc c'est pour dire on est
là tous ensemble c'est beaucoup dans les
paroles il n'y a pas beaucoup d'actes
alors il ya peut-être des gens qui sont
bonnes volontés derrière le problème
c'est que les politiques aujourd'hui
sont dirigés par des industriels et des
lobbys c'est tout le problème c'est pour
ça que l'écologie ça se finit pas juste
à quelques petits coups durs c'est tout
un système qu'il faut changer qu'il faut
bouleverser l'économie dirige seul on ne
s'adapte pas être le cas aujourd'hui
vous dirais que c'est davantage la
société civile qui porte la défense de
l'environnement davantage qu'eux les
vingt leaders des plus grandes
puissances de ce monde
malheureusement et heureusement c'est à
dire que heureusement qu'il ya des
associations qui se bougent des petits
partis tels que le nôtre pour alerter et
sensibiliser
mais je ne ne crois pas en cet comment
dire la désobéissance civile c'est bien
c'est un impact le boycott aussi faut
faire tous à notre échelle mais ça ne
suffit pas s'il n'y a pas des prises de
position au niveau politique des
interdictions claires des pesticides par
exemple de ou d'autres choses du
nucléaire s'il n'y a pas ces
interdictions tout en haut en bas ça
pourra pas suivre forcément parce qu'il
ya des intérêts parce que les
agriculteurs par exemple sont pris dans
une chaîne ils sont obligés de continuer
avec monsanto pour des problèmes
économiques en fait donc tout est lié et
si ça ne part pas d'en haut il se
passera rien mais heureusement qu'il ya
les associations et le peuple pour se
tirer la sonnette d'alarmé les intenses
efforts nécessaires pour lutter contre
le changement climatique représente une
opportunité incroyable pour l'économie
mondiale c'est ce qu'a déclaré tout à
l'heure le président américain joe biden
la lutte pour le climat dissocier de
tout bénéfice économique ça ne marche
pas ça ne marchera pas
je pense qu' il peut y avoir des
résultats des conséquences économiques
très favorable si on se mettait vraiment
dans une démarche de transition
écologique vraiment c'est à dire mettre
des sous dans la recherche dans les
énergies renouvelables ne pas se limiter
à juste mettre des éoliennes en plein
air et éventuellement massacrer des
populations d'oiseaux et de poissons
parce que c'est ça la réalité il n'ya
pas assez d'études quand on lance des
projets c'est pas juste des traités
commerciaux justement c'est tout un
travail en amont de recherche d'étude de
concertation qu'il n'ya pas donc je
pense que si c'était vraiment mis en
place ça créerait des emplois
contrairement à ce qu'on peut dire ça ça
créerait de l'économie alors dans le
même sens qu actuellement un pas dans ce
sens capitaliste et productiviste du
terme mais il n'est qu une économie
circulaire et vertueuse oui je pense que
ça pourrait arriver c'est pas écologiste
est pas synonyme de revenir à la bougie
ou tous pour la ferment pas du tout
c'est vraiment un progrès merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation à
delmas igo porte-parole de rêve revo
écologique pour le vivant